of major major breaking news in the 2016
presidential election it appears as
though the DNC informed the FBI it I
mean this is Watergate to point o if
it's true that DNC headquarters has been
bugged and this is all related to a new
article on mother jones by mother jones
reporter david corn you might remember
that name because shortly before the
twenty twelve election david corn broke
this forty seven percent Mitt Romney
video which we won't rehash now but was
hugely damaging to mitt romney saying
that forty seven percent of americans
are just takers they will always be
takers they will never be makers it was
not good the latest reporting on mother
jones from david corn and i've looked at
the article a few times now explains
that in September the DNC hired a firm
to do an electronic sweep of its offices
because Russian hackers presumably at
the time it was thought had penetrated
their email system as well as those of
other Democratic targets and DNC
officials thought we should really
scrutinize what's going on in our
offices and nothing unusual was found
and you'll remember in late October the
conservative activist James O'Keefe put
out new hidden camera videos targeting
Democrats and now now then interim party
chairwoman interim Party chairwoman
donna Brazile former CNN contributor by
the way Donna Brazile who was let go by
CNN said we should do another sweep that
second sweep according to David corn as
told by Democratic officials found a
radio signal near the office of the
chairman of the DNC suggesting that
there may be an actual listening device
right outside their Babel we are talking
again about Watergate to point o if this
is true a DN via the DNC official says
and I quote here we were told that this
was something that could pick up calls
from cell phones
the guys who did the sweep said it was a
strong indication no device was
ultimately recovered and the DNC put
together this report and they sent it to
the FBI and then they went on to say we
believe it's been given by the bureau to
another agency with three letters to
examine we're not supposed to talk about
it DNC officials are not currently
saying what countermeasures were taken
adding that quote as a general policy we
don't talk about such efforts and the
DNC asked to comment on the record said
that they are they're not going to
comment on the record at this point this
is getting to Watergate level stuff and
what's amazing is you might have seen my
story yesterday yesterday I believe was
yesterday about Fox News reporter Bret
Baier coming out on Fox News and saying
hey FBI sources are telling me an
indictment of Hillary Clinton is likely
and in listening to that I didn't say
this is flat-out untrue but my reaction
was no evidence has been presented all
it is is Brett they are saying unnamed
sources are saying that an FBI
indictment is likely that fell apart
today and Bret Baier has now walked it
back Kellyanne Conway Trump campaign
manager has even admitted yeah that
we've gotta walk it back but it had it
it worked anyway it had its impact and
what is incredible is that if you look
at the facts of the last 24 hours we
have a completely false assertion by Fox
News's Bret Baier which was picked up on
by many other media outlets about a
looming indictment for Hillary Clinton
which no doubt is impacting the
tightening poll numbers in favor of
Donald Trump and now we have learned
that if true we may have seen uh a
Watergate level of
tapping wiretapping essentially a
listening device bugging of DNC
headquarters we are still going to wait
and see what else comes out on this
david corn has a long and reliable track
record this is not something that i'm
going to be ignoring during the weekend
and maybe my by monday we will know more
read the mother jones article in full
which i'm linking to in the comments
section